welcome back to cbs mornings all this
week we have focused on the one-year
anniversary of the return of the taliban
rule in afghanistan now the taliban said
that restored regime would respect the
rights of women so what happened one
year later girls above sixth grade
remain banned from national schools
girls and young women who are determined
to learn are now finding creative ways
you could say to evade the taliban's
restrictions
mts taeb is in afghanistan where he met
with some of them
in the thalabons afghanistan
this is what defiance looks like since
the group's decree barring 12 to 17 year
old girls from most government-run
schools one year ago a growing number
are enrolling themselves into unofficial
schools like this one founded by dr
zainab muhammadi
so you're paying for this all yourself
yes
that must be very difficult to do yes
but i think it it's a
more responsibility you're doing this
for the girls about yeah
yes
although the taliban formally forbids
the education of teenage girls muhammadi
says it largely turns a blind eye to
unofficial schools like hers so long as
strict rules are followed the girls have
to dress fully covered in all black and
as a general rule men cannot come here
so for now her students can take classes
in everything from religious studies
to even crochet
but it's english class that most look
forward to is it important that girls
get an education
as strongly as these girls feel about
being educated
being here isn't easy
what does it feel like coming to a
school like this where you have to dress
very conservatively
and hide to get an education
i feel bad
you feel bad yes
it's a feeling 14 year old huda siddiqui
knows all too well we met her last year
just months after the taliban announced
its ban on girls education one year
later and she's still out of school
what's it been like for you to basically
be stuck at home for the last year like
it was horrifying for me to stay at home
and like not to go out whenever i wanted
to i don't know what's going to happen
in the future but i hope like there are
less restrictions for girls what do you
want the world to know about
afghan girls who want an education
they should force the
taliban's government
to reopen these schools for girls
and
like i don't think they will
any country will recognize them until
they reopen these schools
where there's full recognition abdul
kahar balki is the spokesman for the
taliban's ministry of foreign affairs
at a time when the taliban government is
looking for international recognition
can you not see how
many countries around the world
look at this issue and think
we just can't deal with this government
again this issue is being weaponized
this is the internal matter of
afghanistan and the policy is very clear
when it comes to education
and that is education for all afghan
students
and citizens
now abdulkahar balki insists this is
only a temporary suspension but that of
course is small comfort for
afghanistan's high school age girls
who've been kept out of formal education
for a year now
mts i gotta tell you as a girl person
it's just heartbreaking to see girls
fighting so hard just to get an
education something we all take for
granted then i'm still haunted by your
piece yesterday where you showed us
really terrible pictures of the little
kids who are starving their eyes so big
and their faces so hollowed out so i'm
wondering you've been there all week
what's your perspective what's your
takeaway of what you're seeing and then
to have the guy sitting there saying oh
no we want education for everyone when
clearly that does not appear to be the
case
you know gail i've been coming to
afghanistan since 2010 halfway through
america's longest war and now here we
are one year into the taliban's takeover
of this country and the afghanistan that
i find is one in which foreign soldiers
are gone u.s forces are gone but this is
a far
poorer country and the people of
afghanistan are scared they're scared
they're hungry many don't know when
their next meals are going to be coming
and for girls
from the ages of 12 to 17 they don't
know when they're going to be able to go
back to school and so
one year later one year on from the
taliban takeover in afghanistan is in a
dire dire situation
it seems so so how can mr man sit there
and look at you with a straight face and
say we want education for everyone when
you're telling us a completely different
story i'm always boggled by that
it really is a million dollar question
and what i can tell you gail is that
there are factions within the taliban
who want girls back to school but there
are hardliners very powerful hardliners
who don't want them and they seem to be
winning gail yeah what what people are
afraid of is certainly happening thank
you mts tayab take care of yourself
there we'll talk to you later